well they it was a call it was a couple
of calls and they didn't follow up on
the call and they admitted to it and a
lot of guys and they said they made
changes I didn't find out what exactly
happened to the uh
the police saw the FBI agents that
didn't follow up and a lot of the times
it's it's the same Mo it's someone who's
socially isolated someone who hurts
themselves and hurts other people around
them someone who clearly is a threat
someone who even goes online and says
I'm going to be committing these threats
and that also falls through the cracks I
mean there's just so many of these I
have the lady that called the threat
into the FBI that calls me like
constantly you know not constantly every
few months she checks in with me because
she just feels horrible yeah that she
called and warned them and they never
followed up on it she was someone that
knew the guy personally yeah it was like
an aunt the distant ant that knew he was
uh you know talking about being a school
shooter and she had called the FBI and
the police department and they didn't
follow up correctly and the rest you
know we know what happened
because she knew something was going to
happen she tried to warn the authorities
and then they just sat on their hands
didn't do it and you know we uh you guys
don't follow it as much as I do we just
had that trial he just and after
murdering 17 people uh he still wasn't
committed he didn't get the death
penalty life without parole you know he
said we killed 17 people innocent on
video admitted to it and didn't get the
death penalty I know it's ridiculous why
no death penalty a couple it was like
one or two people voted against the
death penalty in the jury so we're
trying to fix that I've been I spoke
with Governor DeSantis about it there's
a way around it where you you don't need
a full majority uh it could be less it
could be like 70 percent because it was
ridiculous what does a person need to do
in society to get the death penalty if
this thing didn't get it did you sell my
daughter would you support the death
penalty before the shooting well I have
a I personally have a problem with the
way that that penalty works because the
average death row inmate sits there for
20 years before they're executed
peacefully
so I think there could be a lot of
changes to it it should be expedited you
know someone commits a heinous crime
like that it should shouldn't take more
than six months you know to have a trial
and execute them then I would be all for
the death penalty but the way it's set
up now with appeals and they get their
own uh
I looked into it so a death row inmate
doesn't have to work when he's in prison
he doesn't have to get his meals it's
brought to him he gets his own TV he
gets his own security detail so death
row a lot of people after a few years of
being a general population are actually
praying to be on death row that's what
I'm hoping happens to my daughter's
killer all of them on death row are
getting fed meals and they they're
brought to the meals are brought to them
what you know by the correction officers
they don't have to go on a line they
don't have to go on a general population
they have their own security detail
their own TV their own computer and they
just sit most of them it's over 20 years
we talk about the ethics of the death
penalty on the show from time to time
I'm kind of it's uh it's interesting
because I'm like pro-choice but Pro
death penalty maybe I'm just a killer I
would well kill us in a way but I would
be more forward if it was on the 20
years you know to sit 20 years is in a
cell and it's cost you know Broward
County where he was housed it cost the
county four million dollars just keeping
them in the prison system awaiting trial
in Canada they banned the death penalty
but they they're expanding their
euthanasia efforts very aggressively
which is absolutely mind-boggling and
and absolutely totally backwards in my
opinion but if you don't mind telling us
about this a little bit more details
about this FBI story because again it's
either they miss it or they're either
trying to find someone who's mentally
ill and goading them into doing
something as there's also a lot of
documented stories of people coming
together saying hey I had a mentally ill
child the FBI worked undercover and
tried to push them to be extremists
there's a lot of those stories as well
but what did this woman do you have some
of the details here I know you don't
have a lot of the notes in front of you
but but there was two warnings uh one
was uh from like a chat room the first
one came from someone in a chat room to
the FBI and the other one was from like
an aunt of his to call on the FBI that
he was going to be a school shooter wow
and they failed both uh you know both of
them they didn't follow up yeah uh the
police and the sheriff's department
didn't follow up either what's pretty
bad is there was this guy here Deputy
Eason his name was I I remembered his
names he got called the follow-up that
he was going to be the school shooter he
doesn't go and follow up on the tip
right so
of course he was able to go and kill my
daughter that day but he's also one of
the deputies that went to the school and
didn't go in the building that wow you
know so he failed miserably not
following up the lead and then he goes
to the high school and lets kids get
killed inside a building just doesn't go
in with a gun in a vest he's outside
just like Uvaldi uh very similar the
same kind of stories officers outside
this is so like frustrating and so
heartbreaking to hear all the time
officers standing outside not really not
going to affected me big time with
Uvaldi because I I was so after the
Parkland shooting I got so involved with
law enforcement and we made such a stink
out of that there was just the one
Deputy at the school his name was Deputy
Peterson Scott he didn't go in that day
he hid for 45 minutes he didn't hide he
was right by the he went within eight
feet of the door he heard the AR shots
going off I know all this from uh
depositions we did he heard the aort
shots going off and he went to reach and
then he heard it he retreated and then
he hid behind he stared by a wall
for 45 minutes why he heard the gunshots
going off
so he is a lot of people don't notice
but he is being held on felony uh child
endangerment charges I'll be at his
trial I'll be in May but after Parkland
it was there was so much media attention
on these cops not going in and I did so
much press that I thought there's no way
in the world what could a cop not know
if you hear gunshots that you gotta move
towards the gunfire and then you've
already happened and it really killed me
and my son had issues you know with the
anxiety and it was just horrible after
evaldi that these guys I don't know if
you noticed they didn't even go to open
the door in Uvalde you know it wasn't
locked that was all Bs they created a
perimeter blocking parents pushing
parents out so they couldn't stop the
shooting there was parents that had to
that were arrested they had to run away
and then get in the building and then
get their children before the cops did
in Uvalde which is infuriating and
there's and and I remember carvering
Parkland and and reading about it and
being like what were these cops thinking
their arms there's a number of them
they're inside of a school their main
job is to is to you know as they say
Protect and serve their main job is to
run into the line
of fire when it comes to safeguarding
the most innocent the most smallest the
most the purest you know children of our
society and then they they just chilled
it and killed what was that uh that that
we were talking about I think earlier
this week how in China if someone's
driving a car and they accidentally run
someone over
they'll get out of the car and then
murder the person because having to be
financially responsible for a person for
life is worse than getting a few years
in prison for an accidental like you
know vehicular assault or whatever when
there was there was another another
story people uh I can't remember who
brought it up about uh what they do in
China in a similar fashion but when you
get to a point where your Society is
over overly litigious and lacking any
kind of social cohesion these are the
stories we start to see the reason why
the cops and Uvalde bar parents from
going in I don't want to get sued if
they go in there and cause a problem
they're going to say why didn't the
police stop them from going in and then
we get sued and then I lose my job no
you're not allowed to go in I'm not
gonna go in either you want me to risk
my life for your kid never gonna happen
that's where we're at right now people
don't look at each other and say we're
all in this together they look at it and
say every man for himself was that the
vibe you got I'm not that you know the
intentions of the officers on duty at
the time but did you get the vibe that
they didn't want to get legal recourse
or were they just afraid or well they
would just uh there's an expression in
law enforcement it's called Rod retired
on duty Parklands listed as one of the
safest cities in the state so they just
said cushy jobs overweight cops you know
uh they didn't run in where anyone the
coaches they were coaches at the school
that ran in that day unarmed and so
Deputy Peterson now he's getting a
hundred and ten thousand a year pension
for letting my daughter get murdered and
those other 16 people so I'm hoping I'll
be at that trial in May in Broward and
I'm hoping if he's found guilty of
felony charges uh he'll lose his pension
he went and was crazy it was
unbelievable we had we deposed them you
know and I was sitting as close as I am
to Tim with this guy and he came in
holding a Bible you know he thinks he's
gonna God's Gonna help him now that he
let all those people die it's nice to
hear that you said the coaches actually
ran in that day because you know I'm
actually a high school coach myself and
they tell you you can't like if there's
fights you can't touch the kids like Tim
was saying like out of fear of lawsuits
so I'm glad the the coaches of Parkland
actually had they wanted to go in and go
and his theme was uh Aaron Feist and
they actually named the really good
program after him in in Florida it's
called the Aaron Feist Guardian program
where teachers or not law enforcement
could go through this program and be
able to carry on at the schools and I I
sat through it it's really intense and
there's different districts that are
allowing it and they named it in the
bill that we got passed in Florida the
Aaron Feist Guardian program Aaron died
shielding stew this I'm reading about it
yep what was it happened exactly oh he
got it he went into the building uh and
it was just horrible timing went exactly
when he opened the door he was he just
blown away with the gut with the shooter
my daughter actually was uh on the ninth
floor she was uh shot nine times and she
was Shield she shielded another student
and actually at Point Blank Range he
shot her and the bullets went through
her and killed the other girl too so for
45 minutes to an hour the police were
sitting outside five minutes well one
guy with an AR well multiple weapons was
walking around the school one AR that he
had an AR at the Peterson the deputy
that was there could have had a clear
shot at him uh he he went to the door
the shooter was still on the first floor
people a lot of people don't know the
shooter went to the school in an Uber if
you could believe it with the Cabela's
rifle bag she picked them up at his
house the Uber driver drove him to the
school with his rifle bag where he got
out and walked right in through an open
gate where the gate wasn't again was
against protocol the gate should have
been locked you know that and you know
people didn't call the code red
people hidden adults had hidden closets
then you know didn't call a code red
police hit there was like so many things
that went wrong against my daughter that
day that I could make a list what if
just what if certain things would have
happened she'd be alive today do they
have gun-free zones in these in these
places I think every school's like yeah
most of them because I'm wondering about
an Uber driver seeing someone come with
a rifle bag and being like Oh School you
say huh and driving them into this place
where there's you know I guess my view
of it is the law gun free zone is is it
is meaningless oh well people criminals
don't follow gun free zones but even
Uber drivers don't understand yeah you
know they're they're they will pick up a
person with a gun and drive them right
yeah with the rifle big carried it with
the Cabela's rifle bag right into the
school and doesn't never said anything
they thought it was normal to pick up a
kid before school hours no one's even
there you know it was just one of the
things that went against my daughter
that day thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast cast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time